from googly eyed lemurs to camouflaged
geckos and chameleons about 90% of the
species in Madagascar's forests are
found nowhere else in the world earlier
this year I visited a pioneering project
in Madagascar that's aiming to protect
one of the country's few remaining
forests but this isn't just about saving
species it's also about curbing global
warming deforestation is responsible for
about one-fifth of man-made greenhouse
gas emissions so the idea is that in the
near future richer nations will pay to
keep Malagasy forests standing and in
return they'll gain carbon credits to
help offset their own carbon emissions
it's hoped that projects like this will
stem deforestation across the tropics
but to succeed these projects must
overcome the poverty and political
upheaval common to most developing
countries Madagascar may be rich in
biodiversity but it's people are very
poor and depend on exploiting the
forests to survive at sunrise in the
tiny village of under Perrotti
in northeastern Madagascar people load
their slim produce into a dugout canoe
to be taken several hours down the river
for sail the main crop here is rice and
to grow it farmers slash and burn away
the margins of the forest farnetti a
village elder is watching the scene when
he was a boy there were only a few
families here but over the years the
village has grown to hundreds of people
putting even more pressure on the
surrounding forests the Wildlife
Conservation Society is leading a
project to protect the forest around and
apparati in order to trade its carbon on
the international market to make sure
the forest stays standing the Society is
offering the local community alternative
ways to make a living they're working
with villagers to increase rice
production on existing field
and kickstart ecotourism in the area
projects like this are popping up around
the developing world in anticipation of
the United Nations climate conference in
Copenhagen this December the aim of the
conference is to forge a new global
climate deal to replace the Kyoto
Protocol rainforest nations like
Madagascar hope that this deal will
support a carbon trading scheme that
will compensate them for protecting
their forests for the carbon trading
scheme to work first the forests must be
measured
I followed the Wildlife Conservation
Society team deep into micariff forests
to see how they make their carbon
calculations the first step is to
measure the carbon stored in a small
sample of trees and leaf litter later
they extrapolate the data to cover the
entire forest the second step is to work
out how much carbon could be saved if
the project reduces to forestation
and therefore how much carbon can be
traded on the carbon market but in a
country plagued by poverty and political
instability it's almost impossible to
guarantee that a certain amount of
carbon will stay locked up in a forest a
military backed coup earlier this year
for example led to a surge in illegal
logging and a lot of unforeseen carbon
emissions in the long term it's hoped
that carbon payments from richer nations
will filter down into local communities
and lessen their reliance on the forests
but right now this village in Madagascar
seems a world away from reaping the
much-lauded rewards of carbon trading
you